bonjour j'habite il faut les literies 32
ans j'ai créé une activité de services à
la personne on intervient au domicile
des particuliers soit pour des services
à la famille comme soutien scolaire
garde d'enfants des services pour le
confort jardinage ménage et le repassage
aide ménagère est également l'aide aux
personnes âgées et dépendantes donc j'ai
créé l'activité en fin 2012 je vais
avoir bientôt deux ans d'activité et
j'ai actuellement quatorze salariés dans
mon agence plus la création de mon
propre emploi donc deux emplois d'avenir
à temps plein depuis l'ouverture de
lagence donc la première année a été un
petit peu compliqué avec la le parcours
du combattant que c'est pour créer son
entreprise
mais avec les aides que j'ai pu avoir
dans le cadre de la création
d'entreprise que ce soit des querelles
entre en atomes de commerce où tous les
structures qui existent déjà que c'est
aussi un bonheur de pouvoir créer des
emplois au quotidien et qui s'adapte à
tout le monde on peut avoir des temps
partiels mais pour des personnes qui
souhaitent travailler mais gardez aussi
un côté aide à sa famille je vais élever
ses enfants ou une personne qui
recherche valmary véritablement un
nombre d'heures important donc on est en
capacité de répondre à ses besoins et
aussi de pouvoir apporter une réponse à
l'évolution de notre société pour nos
gramounes qui sont de plus en plus soit
isolé ou soient ne peuvent pas ou n'ont
pas les moyens d'être
mise en établissement pour la retraite
donc il doit les garder dans le cocon
familial et c'est vraiment un bonheur de
participer à ce projet de vie